foreign
you
okay we can call a meeting to order
and a reminder to everybody using their
microphone because we're tape recording
this
because we don't have a
well weiler wasn't here to correct me so
i didn't know what to do
looking for a motion on the minutes so
moved
second
motion made
by hennessy second by weiler any
additions deletions or corrections to
the minutes
seeing none all those in favor aye aye
thank you mr chairman uh for the record
steve smith the director of audits um
the childcare licensing unit we just
presented at the fiscal last friday so
that is now a
done a done audit and uh released
board of dental examiners
this is
we we just had a one year anniversary on
this audit back in december
all of our observations are in the hands
of the board as well as oplc
they have provided responses to us on
some of them and they just got
possession of the last batch within the
last couple of weeks
the responses that we've gotten back
we're trying to reconcile and work with
them to help them better understand
where we're coming from
as well as help them to
respond more appropriately if i can put
it that way to make sure they're
addressing the recommendations and they
understand them
and again because this encompasses both
the
board operations as well as it goes into
many areas of oplc
it's going to be another lengthy report
i think we have about 30 some odd
observations
and
so we're attempting to work with the
board uh there's look there is a little
bit of frustration on their part being
unfamiliar with the process
as and the fact that they are part-time
board members and understanding things
so we're trying to
work with them and and work through it
um so that's uh our hope is that at some
point this spring we'll be able to tie
it up and and present it um to fiscal
so
i have a package here for you
representative weiler
thank you representative
is
is the problem the board or is the
problem
oplc
i would say right right now
i wouldn't i i i don't i i'm careful to
use the word problem
because it may just be an educated an
education process on their part or just
not really understanding what their
what
understanding their control environment
or lack thereof and what should be
i would say oplc i think gets it it's
largely the board board members and of
course they meet once a month and so
trying to get them to
convene and to
work through these issues
third on the list there is the mental
health workforce requirements uh if if
the committee remembers you approved
that topic and gave it to us last last
meeting and then fiscal subsequently
approved that so
we are currently
scoping that out and
beginning some planning for that so at
our next meeting we'll have a scope
statement for you to approve on that
topic and then the fourth one is the um
according to chapter law is the uh
review i guess or
a special project that we're doing on
the new hampshire retirement system in
the health care subsidy
we're close to the end on that we've
drafted a report we're just reviewing it
now maybe a couple of outstanding
questions with department administrative
services and new hampshire retirement
system
but we're we should be
within the next month hopefully
bringing that letter to
to my kane and then subsequently to the
fiscal committee so
so in terms of our current ongoing
audits that's that's a quick update
um
on topic number three what you you'll
see in your package a pre-scope
statement
that we were asked to do on special
education
and
with a few options in the back of a
performance audit like how we could
approach with a performance audit
the primary author of this is
john clinchy is here if you would like a
presentation or have him walk you
through it
we'd be happy to do that
otherwise we can
you can just discuss it
let's let's have john do the overview
and
the result of the study committee led us
to
seek a much broader scope than just the
dispute resolution process
and you may have discovered some of the
issues
thank you for the record my name is john
clinch i'm a senior audit manager with
the office of legislative budget
assistant good afternoon and thank you
we prepared this pre-scope statement
based on the work that the
alternative dispute resolution
committee had done uh we do have a
description of of alternate
through the alternative dispute
resolution processes that's on page
three
um there's basically three of those
um but we were feeling from the this
committee that um
they wanted a little bit broader look at
special education in in general
so we prepared this uh pre-scope
statement with
frequency of the disability on table one
on page one
gives you an idea of what the
disabilities that the
children are dealing with
then we have
the bureau of special education support
which is the
organization within the department of
education that oversees most of the
special ed programs
within the bureau of special education
support there are three offices the
office of finance and data management
the office of special special education
training and monitoring
and the office of special programs
and within those there's a little
description of each
on page two i can go over those if you'd
like
okay the office of finance finance and
data management
deals with all the federal grants for
special education in the state
court ordered placements
and
the new hampshire special education
information system
they're also responsible for all the
data that's that is uh maintained by the
bureau of special education services
and they they
create and submit the state performance
plan and
audit
performance report for the u.s
department of education
the office of special education training
and monitoring
they train field relate fields related
to special education those would be the
i was involved a few years on
as you know the charter schools don't
have special ed sections
so it's responsibility of the sending
district to provide the special ed
that's been kind of a problem area and
i would like kind of a little closer
examination within that
bureau on that because i think that
there's all sorts of arrangements some
work very well together the district and
the and the um
and the charter school in other cases
they seem to be putting up road blocks
and making difficulties and
i don't think it's overseen enough
from what i've heard when i hit a
committee on this anyway
just i want to mention that
as a side area to look at in those areas
thank you john okay i i think that's
something that can be looked at
we have as steve mentioned we have sort
of a menu
of audit
topics that you could look at
um
they're numbered a through d
a is the alternative dispute resolution
audit
that focuses pretty strongly just on the
dispute resolution process
we can add on to that item b
which is
looking at the costs of special ed
in the state
the performance audit there would look
at the resources and uses of special ed
funds and the efficiency and
effectiveness of does management of the
special ed costs in new hampshire
grant management collection of financial
data
from local school districts and other
entities
we last did a performance audit in that
area in 1999
so it's been quite a while
since we've done anything there
that could be done in conjunction with
the next item or it could be done
independently
the next item is
data collection and analysis
that's also through the office of
financial and data management
the statute requires that the doe or
collect organize and analyze data about
and that involves they primarily oversee
the new hampshire
special education information system
which i don't believe has ever been
looked at
so that's kind of an important
project
and then the last thing
i think this answers uh representative
weiler's uh question
um
statute requires the uh division of
learning services or learning support
to help school districts meet their
responsibilities regarding special ed
students
develop and analyze information on
issues and problems of regional and
statewide importance
assist school districts in managing
these issues and monitor and maintain
information about national and regional
trends
that would be more of a generally
focused audit on
the
not just the bureau of special ed
services but a larger one
dealing with special ed that cross-cuts
the different bureaus
and i think that's something that could
be
that could focus on
the charter
the charter and local school district
difficulties
so we have
um
there's lots of different ways we can
take this you can select one or two or
more off of the menu here
or we can do
something more specific that you request
it's it's really up to you how you want
us to so here's what the study committee
uncovered
was
we took testimony and i gave you the
binder i had a testimony a four-inch
binder and not a happy story in the
whole binder right
and what appears to be happening
is
that in combination with
a law firm and the school districts
they
seem to ally themselves together against
the parents
and the wholes the whole scenario as
this the parents get discouraged and
beaten down until they give up
and then that seems to be
how we've satisfactorily
respond resolution in the special
education process
so in the meantime we have
hundreds
of
little children who get to be bigger
children who
don't learn how to read
and become unemployable
for some reason we're spending a lot of
money
to produce the very
large number of unemployable
adult human beings
and that's the
purpose of our requesting this audit is
to find out what's going on there and
what are the incentives that cause this
to happen to all these children
so
you're the guys
to get to the bottom of this
however far you have to take it
but this is a very expensive and serious
problem
for all of these families and all of
these children and all the well-meaning
people working in the education system
who are
trying to educate
people who are difficult to educate
and
because a parent gives up
is not a successful resolution to the
problem
so we need to find out what's
what's going on there so that we can do
something about it
to stop this from happening
but we can't just somebody suggested
they said well just build another prison
for them and just put them in the prison
because they're only going to get in
trouble the rest of their life anyway so
at least we'll keep them warm and dry
and
and dressed and give them some
meaningless occupation
but
this can't go on like this
you just can't have all these people
at loose ends because
they can't read they can't
do the math they don't understand the
science
and because they've been oftentimes
kept in a separate room in the school
where they can apparently play video
games or watch television but just don't
disturb the regular classroom
so
what we can do about the lack of people
that are able to train people
that's also a problem for the college
and university systems because they're
not producing people
and
we need to know what what's going on
besides how successful the law firms are
that's not a satisfactory resolution to
this
so i leave that in your able hands
senator
thank you mr chairman totally concur
i'm
curious and more than curious i think we
need to figure out what what are the
metrics that we use
to evaluate the system and also to
evaluate your success in in
in you know bringing back a report that
both identifies the project the problems
uh you know for us
with in a way that we can address them
legislatively if necessary so i'm not
sure what the metrics would be and maybe
john the study might provide some
guidance on that
so i'm going to say
thank you um
letter a dispute resolution process and
looking at the
the mediation process when you
when you do the
audit of this section which i would
encourage you to do
in your mediation on the second and
third lines
well first through third it says in
mediation either party may be
accompanied and advised by individuals
with specific knowledge or training with
respect to the needs of children and
disabilities is there a way to some of
senator reagan's points for us to look
at
and count
for these mediation processes
who is coming
for the child
and and the parent or the guardian and
who is coming on the other side and and
who these um
special knowledge individuals are
so that we can see
or
to what all of the the four inch binder
said is that these parents don't have
the special knowledge that they need and
it's very expensive
to
go out and look for an individual to
advocate for your child's behalf on what
in the school should be doing that to
begin with so i want to look at what
who's coming to these meetings and
and is it a is it a balanced and fair
and
process
that's a very good point
um when i that's i had that same
question as i was writing this
background here
and uh i went to the the department of
education website and i was looking for
that information at least give give me
an idea of how many how many mediations
do they have how many dispute resolution
hearings do they have and i couldn't
find any of that on their website
it doesn't mean it doesn't exist there
and it and i would presume it exists at
the department level
but we base when we write these we write
them on public information that's
available um on the web or other sources
the laws
um so we haven't contacted the
department of education yet that would
be part of the audit topic that we would
uh go and find that information out and
we would present that in the audit
report
you're not going to get your answers
from the department of education
because they're in self-protect mode
about a lot of this
commissioner's not aware a lot of what
karen
one of the things that is very difficult
is the rules
that are part of idea
you know the the federal law
and that in fact
in my opinion
is what is causing a lot of this to
occur
because
the school system can always say well
id idea says this
therefore
you know and
and it's
it's very difficult
to
and i'm not even sure that there's
anyone
at the state level who is an advocate
for
the parents in this regard
because if you if you don't understand
idea
and you don't understand where
you know what what they're saying
then
the disputes generally end up negative
for the child
senator khan
thank you chairman um
so
one of the issues i think
is there 30 000 students
that are receiving special education
services
that that's a that's a lot of
a lot of students
obviously we're doing well by some
i think trying to sort out
uh this population
and
we can't we can't turn our back on these
but another
topic
that i hope that we do pick up on is if
we haven't looked in 22 years
at
how the various sources of funds that go
how
it fits into the overall
delivery now i think that that's an
important feature
we know that i mean you're going to find
out that it costs
twenty thousand dollars above
whatever we're paying per student
for special education per special
education student
and where those dollars are coming from
i think is a important
matter for us to understand
so i hope that you will pick up i hope
this this committee will encourage at
least
part b
which probably requires part c to go
with it
uh uh so that we
this this
we just ought to have a policy policy
ought to be based on on some of the data
that
we can hopefully get out of this system
uh
and from the department and from the
districts
because clearly we know that there are
29 000 students here
uh
all right i think that
so i mr chairman i hope that will
empower the
auditors to
delve into this not just on the
complaint side but on the overall volume
the sources of funds that we're putting
towards it the data that we collect and
need in order to con to develop good
policy
senator dallas andrew thank you mr
chairman uh just a question of the of
the data that's been presented
these numbers came from the from the
department of education yes they did and
how how do they how do they
get this data what's it what's what's
their methodology to make sure that
these things are
properly reported and they're properly
identified that's a very good question
and i'm afraid i don't have an answer
for you that's one of the things that we
would determine during the audit
is what is the reliability of this data
and where the what are the sources it
comes from
at some level it's got to come from the
so how is it tailored up when it gets to
the state department of education
i i think that would be fundamental
the validity of this data and how these
categories uh have been selected uh for
for people now i i see deaf and blind as
7 17.
we have a we have a program at the
interest of a definite deaf and hard of
hearing
we have a full section of the school
that's allocated this we used to take
students from the outside
so i think there's there seems to be an
inconsistency here but i think
if you could focus in on that i mean
that's the base of the audit the audit
has to be derived
from the people that we're serving
and if we know who we're serving and
then then i think we could attempt to
serve them properly but if they're not
properly identified then
it goes back to what you said john they
put them they just throw them to the
side right and they're still passing
kids through
okay and uh you know just uh promoting
them
based on time thank you mr chairman
senator guido
thank you mr chair i look at the data
that's presented 29 195 children
out of an 80 000 student population so i
would have to assume that some of these
children are receiving multiple of these
i refuse to believe that 37 and a half
percent of our school children are in
special ed
so that would be something in terms of
the data uh again
i have to be
i just out of 160
160 it's still a high percentage it's 15
yeah
yeah it is
i thought it was eighty thousand
no it's 160 000 students
down from 200 000 about
12 15 years ago my mistake but still
high percentage
yeah
that's what a serious problem it is
uh if i if i could if i could mr
chairman
this
everything that
is in this proposal is extremely
important
okay but
the problem is how long do we want this
audit to take
okay
and if
a b c and d
in my humble opinion
in order for them to do a good job it's
going to take them two years just to
to get to it
to get through all of it
and if if that's what we want
i i don't have a problem with that
but
that's a lot of stuff here and if you
know i don't know how familiar you are
with special ed but um
it's uh
it's a rabbit hole that has no
has no bottom
so anyhow i just i just ask if we
how far do we want them to go
i would not like to see them proceed
only just far enough to not reach a
conclusion
and it's been 23 years
right so maybe two years
i mean that's absolutely fine i just i
just don't want us to get our
expectations up
that
we're going to get this in six months
because it's not going to happen
i think it's important enough that we
don't need to try to rush it because
yeah okay that's fine i just i agree i
think in the past 23 years it's really
grown
in the past 23 years what i see is a big
growth in the bureaucracy
at the local levels i mean
in some school districts that
the staff almost
is equal to the number of
coded students that getting a little out
of hand
senator hennessey thank you mr chairman
to uh
representative umberger's
point could we break this up into two
separate audits do a as one
um
no
i wouldn't do that based on the look on
your face mr chairman i'm assuming now
[Laughter]
so i had the good fortune once upon a
time
to be interviewed in the preliminary
interviews for a performance audit
and
it wasn't quite like
being in the back room at the police
station but it was a pretty intense
process
and i said
you know there is a skill to this
so it was mr clinch that did the
interview
smiling
but they're they're good people to allow
them to follow their nose and find
find the correct conclusion so
if if i may um i can repeat back some of
what i've heard
i hear loud and clear that there's an
interest in dispute resolution and i
think that's something that can be done
pretty focused and fairly quickly
as a stand-alone audit
and then the other part is
more of a general
special ed audit that looks at costs
looks at how ieps are formed in the
support that the department of education
uh
provides
um
to the local school districts and and
that would be more of a broader spectrum
of of looking more in depth at the
special ed system
and i think that's a separate audit and
that would take a little bit longer but
you could have your fairly focused and
uh
dispute resolution audit done first
and then
perhaps you could you could turn us
loose on the more general
if that would you're being be your
advice to how do we get to
answers to questions
how do we
how do we stop this
waste of human talent
from
being eaten up by a
system that
doesn't
operate
to the most benefit to their customers
you know
which are too young and too small to
figure out what to do
so so you're pitting parents against law
does not come out good
if i made mr truman i think
i kind of concur with um
with john that i think
to help the committee at least begin to
get some answers quicker
we could do this dispute resolution
process but as we gain understanding and
get more information
recognizing the other concerns the other
questions
we can certainly start with that and
then as we get further down the road if
if it would seem like
efficiently and effectively we can
incorporate some of these other concerns
into the audit we can
come to you and ask ask for the topic to
be expanded
or
again as subsequent when we finish this
one we can move on to
that other area so it is a
it's something that we can come back to
you and and
you can certainly expand the scope once
you approve it we're gonna have to come
back with the scope statement anyways
once we begin to interact with the with
the agency at that point based on our
understanding we can
make a recommendation that we also
incorporate perhaps some of these other
concerns
if it makes sense
so so
the behavioral problem children
seem to produce the most disputes
because they're very difficult to work
with
and very hard to see any light come
through
so
in the binder you've got
access to
some pretty damaged witnesses
being parents of special needs children
so
if you can address them you can find out
the areas of most concern i'm sure
there's a lot of areas that
are not of concern that they are able to
handle and help the children adjust to
so
khan
mr chairman uh and
respecting the uh
ideas that were
presented
by our auditors
um
i would hope that the scope statement
would cover a b and c
you could indicate that there is an
interim report that is
but i think in order for us to
i just would hate to see us
say that we can
look at one part here and and and arrive
at good conclusions without having
looked at
okay so what are the funding sources
how are how are they derived how are
they distributed
allocated
uh
maybe pick up on on
representative weiler's question about
uh charter
students and because they're clearly in
these numbers
uh and
and and what the data
uh
systems
allow us to look at on a recurring basis
so i i think if
i i think
i would hope that you'd come back with
something that's comprehensive just
indicated you'd have a report
anyone else before we
so
are we then going to do the suggested
does that require emotion or we just let
well i guess i guess that's the question
if i may mr chairman is is do you want
us to
do some more digging before you
officially give us a topic to present to
fiscal
or do you
or
in other words is the committee
ready to give us
the question to be answered or the topic
that we can then go to fiscal and
actually begin i think we could use more
information because this is
and this is a very broad topic
and it touches on a lot of
happy spots and a lot of sore spots and
so
okay
so we'll meet again here for scope
statement
hmm
oh
okay
and
next we have weatherization and
fixed-wing aircraft
yes and
those uh the committee at prior meetings
just kind of tabled those but didn't
like do away with them
um i will and at the back of your
package i think in particular address
senator geider's
questions or requests um there's some
information um
and steve lavoy from department of
safety is here so he'd be happy to walk
you through
the memo and some of the data that
he provided to us and to you the
committee
so that that's up to you but uh our goal
is to get at least one or two two topics
so
beyond these um we're not aware of any
other
that are
so think of things in your committees
now
that don't seem to be working quite
right
and propose
good afternoon mr chair members of the
committee steve lavoy director of
administration for the department of
safety
tries to start
the discussion related to the benefits
and risks of owning versus leasing the
i think the
i'll summarize it for you
because the
the reality is is it's a complicated uh
question
and there are i kind of view two sides
to the coin one there's a fiscal
component um which which option is the
least expensive but then the second side
is there's an operational component
and what type of operational impact
would one decision have over the other
so currently the state police own their
fixed-wing cessna 182-t
aircraft and that's used for
aircraft enforcement activities
and one of the benefits of owning the
aircraft is that there are no limits on
hours
if you lease an aircraft much like a
like a motor vehicle there's often hour
limits
and then the cost structure built over
over time if you exceed those at those
yearly hour limits
those don't exist with the owned
aircraft
you also control your maintenance
evolutions those typically would be at
the
discretion of the
lessor on when those maintenance have to
occur some obviously have to happen
based on hours
of use and and must occur others are
more discretionary
and then finally there's direct control
over operations
that state police currently
have over their existing owned
plane
they would lose some of that option from
a leased perspective because of those
maintenance intervals that might be
required by contract
another consideration has to do with uh
leasing out the entire operation so not
just the aircraft and the maintenance
but also the pilots
there's some concerns there with
availability
there's some concerns there with the
what type of of pilot you're you're
receiving from the vendor you can't
typically in those arrangements choose
if you prefer pilot a over pilot b uh
when an operation uh needs to be needs
to be flown uh and the other issue there
might be whether or not we can afford a
lease that would allow for 24 7 response
operations from a pilot perspective
so these these are all unknown costs at
this point we have not done any formal
request for information
from any any available
aircraft leasing companies
we did
do some initial uh review to see if
there were any planes available that
would meet our needs it does not look
like there
there are many i'm not saying there
aren't any i'm sure that we could find
some but it doesn't look like there's a
significant leasing market for the type
of plane that we currently operate there
are other types of planes that are
available and we'd have to determine if
those would fit our operating needs
and then finally there was some initial
research done
with other state police and city police
departments of
similar size
to state police
maryland state police delaware state
police new york city police and san
diego police department
all of them own and operate their their
planes in the same way that new
hampshire state police currently does
so whether or not there's a practice in
law enforcement of leasing
we'd have to do more research this is a
very small sample
but i do think that um
industry by industry it's probably a
different answer depending upon which
industry you're you're focused in
because of the limitations and benefits
of a lease arrangement
so this memo just
details some of those considerations um
some of the initial research we've done
so far
again i'd reiterate that we currently
own our fixed wing aircraft it was
purchased back in
2008 for four hundred thousand dollars
based on some web searches the
approximate value is is three hundred
and eighty thousand dollars the aircraft
do retain their value because of that
maintenance and rebuild on the engines
that happens occasionally or
periodically
we're not at this point planning on
replacing
the the aircraft but when that time
comes the
division and the department would be
open to looking at all options including
leasing including lease to own options
because all these factors could change
at that point in time
and i'd be happy to answer any
additional questions the committee may
representative weiler
thank you mr chairman
i had an opportunity to speak to a
couple of troopers when we were meeting
in manchester that had wings on their
chest and
i'm wondering how many of them are there
that are eligible to to fly these
airplanes or to ride along
so we have two civilian pilots
the troopers are looking for the exact
name tactical flight officers so they're
not flying the aircraft but they're in
the aircraft
communicating with the troopers on the
ground and operating the equipment
to to conduct the enforcement activity
and one of the
follow-up one of the other things i
learned was that there's quite often
three on the ground that are involved
three troopers on the ground that are
involved in any of these things but
they said
that they kind of go after the people
that are going more than 80 miles an
hour and
that's the big ticket so that it pays
for this program by
not going after the guy that's 10 miles
over the speed limit or something they
so that's hundreds of dollars tickets
these ones they catch i saw the other
day 127 miles an hour
but
you wouldn't need an airplane to figure
but um
it looks like
it's paying for itself and i would
imagine you
if you rented an airplane did you look
into any of the hourly costs if you
rented a similar size airplane
we weren't able to find anything that
was
comparable to what we currently have and
so we we haven't been able to go to that
level of detail
the
belief on our end is that
when you're entering into that lease or
rental arrangement the costs of the
maintenance are going to be rolled into
the expense and you're going to absorb
those one way or the other
the benefit is new equipment potentially
at the end of that term
but for aircraft that are used in this
capacity
that may not be as large a benefit for
some other types of industries
would seem to be pretty limited in the
hours they could fly you'd need daylight
clear skies more or less and
good visibility so
you know 30 hours a month or so is about
what you're going to get i guess thank
anyone else
senator
motion made we have a second to remove
this from the list i'll second it
and seconded by umberger
any
discussion all those in favor
opposed
and
the weatherization program did we
no
it could it could be uh something the
air
could be something the arp program could
throw some money at
keep the
yeah
keep the windows closed
but looking at the scope of time and so
on they can have to use that money and i
don't know if
by the time we got the the audit back
whether it'd be much time to to put in
for that in the program so anyway it's
just a thought
if i might
i mean the weatherization program
something that should be audited
i mean it's we we are putting money
all the all the time into weatherization
and um
i'm not sure whether it's ever been
reviewed or not
but
you know they have rules
and
and i just think that
it
it should proceed
so your motion is to continue the
program
the audit of the program yes okay
sure
we have a motion in a second to continue
with the weatherization audit
any discussion
all those in favor aye aye
stave the way of anything else
we don't i will um we'll draft up a
letter for the fiscal meeting next month
and for your signature for this this
weatherization topic sure okay
okay okay
seeing no further business
you